how's it going everybody we are live
welcome to the team cast IRL podcast I'm
here with my buddy Adam how's it going
everybody
that's Adam for showing up and we went
and saw birds-of-prey last night we
didn't we didn't do the show because I
had a sore throat and because I record
for like three hours a day I was like
man it's probably not worth it to risk
it and then so he's gonna sit around and
then I was like well you know what we've
been ragging on birds-of-prey
why don't we go see it spoiler alert
yeah I doubt anyone cares we are gonna
spoil this this is one of the worst
things I have ever seen ever it was bad
it was bad gosh
all right I'm gonna show you something
something offensive that will trigger
you before we before we do if you want
to get in the super Jets and feel free
to do so you can click the like button
we will get to your comments but there's
gonna be a long segment because we are
going to rip this movie to shreds as you
see from the title this movie was cringy
woke trash the entire movie yep the
whole every there was not a single man
in the movie who was like good in any in
any way all men were terrible all of
them and and and oh man oh dude I don't
want to like I don't know if we should
go through it like act by actors like I
think we might relive it and it's
traumatic right because there's
different scenes that I remember like Oh
seriously seriously there's like the the
first one that I noticed was the the
female cop she goes to her subordinate
like hey she's like the veteran cop -
standing with her let's give a basic
context okay birds of prey is Harley
Quinn from the DC Universe with some
other DC characters I have no idea what
the movies about and I saw it the other
night but it's basically Harley Quinn
and these other female characters
teaming up yeah and now we begin right
so it cuts to this cop and she's like oh
yeah this isn't this happened and then
she's got her other her new partner like
pestering her like now that didn't
happen how did that happen that how did
that happen like that and she's like
yeah it definitely happened it was one
person who did this and then she turns
to like a you know a regular cop and
goes I'm gonna need ballistics check
ballistics on the car out there and he
he looks at her
founded and then he turns to the newer
man detective and goes mmm like like
shrugs I don't do do I do this sir
should I should I do what the woman says
it's like what that's the movie in what
world does that happen like she's the
senior crime scene but right and she
says to a cop go do the ballistics
report I need that they're gonna be like
yes sir all right yes ma'am done but to
get the bigger picture basically every
single motivation was a caricature of
patriarchy I'm not even kidding in I'm
just going for it full spoilers I kid
you not in one scene the motivation for
the bad guy to kill Harley is that quote
I have a vagina oh my god not kidding
you're right she says it she says wait
wait though no no no no no it literally
said the words I have a vagina oh that's
on the screen and I kid you not it then
says I voted for Bernie not a joke
literally happened that was the
motivation to get killed the bad guy had
no motivation at all made no sense none
and he was like dude this movie oh man
all right so there's there's a scene
where he's like okay first of all first
of all for it was not a feminist film it
was a like female Krynn okay yeah yeah a
feminist film you'd think would be like
strong women's you know being like ray
from Star Wars
it's feminist II in that she's strong
and she's got great power like Wonder
Woman is a better example because it's
an island of like awesome and wrong
women but that's right by literally
where she comes from here's what I mean
here's what I mean she's an awesome like
that's not that's not what I mean woman
you know superheroes a a traditionally
woke film puts women on a pedestal like
right in ghostbusters they're smart
scientists with PhDs and all the men are
just dumb
this was like if okay the Harlequins
motivation is that her boyfriend broke
up with her and she's upset about it the
first like 90 minutes of the film by the
way no note of the whole the whole movie
but no no but the first 30 minutes the
film is literally her complaining that
he broke up with her yeah and now she's
got to find her own way and then it's
like oh her
or her friends were like yeah she'll go
right back to him she's just like no I'm
not going to throws the drinks down and
like storms off do and then talks about
how she I figured it misses him that's
like I figured what is going on I
figured it out I know what that was
supposed to be please explain what so
they've experimented with woke feminists
films right okay but they always give
them motivations that are masculine
saving live saving the world right is
that masculine or is that just simply
like a human sure sure a traditional
motivation okay okay I think this was
like what if we made a superhero movie
with the motivations being completely
female so could you not get this the
motivation of the cop is that her
promotion was given to a man who didn't
deserve it you know I'm not kidding and
then finally when she's like I know what
the bad guys up to he's going for the
diamond he got the guy who wasn't
supposed to be the promotion goes all
right get on it and points to the man
and says you do it juice but this is my
case and he's like we need something we
can work with need actual evidence yeah
your hunch that this is what they're out
my god but you just told the other guy
to go out like now research it and
here's here's the best part a huntress
you might know who huntresses the
crossbow killer the crossbow killer
she's a character in DC and she kills
people the crossbow not even in the
movie okay she is but it's like this
weird thing where Harley Clin was Harley
Quinn is like doing stuff and then it'll
show you like 10 seconds of Huntress
doing one thing and then that's it and
then at the end it's like there's
Huntress yeah and I'm like but she had
literally nothing to do with this movie
the guys she killed had literally
nothing to do this movie at all
yeah they forced that whole storyline
into it it's about like how her family
got killed and it's like that's the
motivation of the bad guy because he
wants their fortune which is written in
the diamond somehow so he needs the
diamond but to get the fortune of her
family that so I guess okay no full stop
no the story starts with Harley Quinn
trying to buy an egg sandwich right
right right the egg sandwich gets
dropped in the street and it ends with
her finally getting an egg sandwich
that's a lot what the store is her
trying to get back to the shop to get
the egg sandwich I'm not kidding this is
the only part
the movie that I have any kind of
identification with getting the egg
sandwich you could you can you can see
how it'd be devastating to lose your egg
sandwich okay okay okay we-we've we're
going nuts because we've got so much to
say but I have to have to do this
alright check this out
Rotten Tomatoes gave it an 88% audience
score I'm calling shenanigans yeah me
too I got a theory man no way here's my
here's my pop culture conspiracy theory
way
I think rot so back before there was
movie reviews if a movie was bad people
still had to go see it based on the
marketing so you'd go in the newspaper
and see what you know Siskel and Ebert
had to say right and maybe it was hit or
miss okay but for the most part you are
like well I guess I gotta go see it with
Rotten Tomatoes and social media and
word-of-mouth now being extremely and
videos like this movies now are getting
destroyed Rotten Tomatoes has been
constantly like deleting audience
reviews and blocking audience reviews
now I'm gonna go and say these are fake
yeah and I and I think I have a good
reason to argue as such first of all one
of the reviews says Mary Elizabeth
Winstead nailed it as Huntress and I was
like I got you life she's not in the
movie she has like five lines when she
is in the movie she has no lines until
the very end when she has literally like
30 seconds to a minute of screen time
not exaggerating it's Renee sure she's
just complaining that she's not the
crossbow killer - it's right exactly yes
I am so so basically happens is
throughout the movie of Harley quit like
okay oming first of all time jumps back
and forth the movie starts with the
narration from Harley Quinn and then
somehow just stops at one point goes to
cartoon I think further part it was the
beginning well no it was it wasn't the
very beginning she it was oh it was a
born of those times where it went back
she's like you know what let me better
explain how I came to be and then we get
all of her life they were trying to make
I guess like feminist Deadpool yeah that
made you like she like looks at the
camera on Winx a couple times and like
smiles the camera and stuff and it's
like she's talking to you it's very
obvious but you know what man you know I
saw this quote on here I have it right
here and someone goes the the movie was
surprisingly decent
good some people are obviously calling
it trash because they're probably
threatened and triggered by a female
lead comic book and it's like a comic
book movie I just laugh at these remarks
and it's like what
no Wonder Woman was an incredible movie
and that's a well women book I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna I won't I won't pull
my punches for the sake of trying to
claim I like a movie Wonder Woman was a
good movie I give it a B+ may be a -
yeah it was a good best movie in the
world but it's an enjoyable movie I'll
watch it definitely I love that scene
when she jumps out of the trenches yeah
her shields taken the 50k all those guys
all the guys are like but here but but
Wonder Woman had some feminist moments
where she like walks into the council
tall dudes and you're like is this your
assistant or whatever what are they said
so it was like you know Wonder Woman was
a bit feminist II but the thing is I I
figured it out I figured it out
because we were talking on the other day
and I said I think I understand why this
is bad first of all this is ghostbusters
2016 all over again yeah every man was
stupid or evil right the only guy who
wasn't technically evil his spoilers by
the way we've gone nuts is his black
mask makes a guy he forces him to take a
knife and cut a woman's dress off and
he's like shaking is like I'm so sorry
does he does it yeah so either there's
one feeble weak loser and then all the
other guys are cringy insane right black
mask
okay okay let's start over yeah yeah
black mask she before she breaks up with
Joker she does whatever she wants right
and so she's like because I'm dating mr.
J nobody wants to come after me and then
right after she broke up she but I
haven't told anyone
right they're special oh no that's what
I mean she was broken up with him right
and because they were broken up nobody
would go after but as soon as she
announced her breakup by blowing up a
chemical plant everyone's like that
means she broke up with mr. J and then
they find the J necklace and then she's
wearing a female symbol in her neck oh I
didn't even notice yeah yeah anyway now
all of a sudden everybody wants to kill
her right right so here's really funny
the whole the only semblance of a plot
is the MacGuffin chase of like where's
the diamond and they're like boop boop
boop running around trying to find the
diamond right
so dumb so anyway while she's randomly
trying to be killed by all sorts of
different people this is this was where
my brain my eyeballs look like we're
about to burst from my skull and my
brain was turning to goo when they
finally kidnapped
Harley Quinn for some reason black mask
is like Harley Quinn's now a joker I'd
like to
so then he the kidnapper that catcher
right he brings her in ties her up and
that's when the scene is where she's
explaining that he hates her she goes
there's many reasons why he hates me and
then it says I have a vagina but then it
flickers through a bunch of things I
don't member all of them but one of them
was voted for Bernie yeah yeah I was
like dude but then the best part happens
it zooms it in her face and turns into a
dance sequence where all of the henchmen
are going like doing like a weird dance
with her and she's going like this like
yeah wearing like a nice classy yeah
19:30 and it says it's a music video
where she sings diamonds are a girl's
best friend or somebody or is that it I
know I know there was that was a mover
it was that was it
I'm like it's like ghostbusters dude
when they break out in the dance
sequence with with did you percentage
worth on something that explained that
what was that oh this is the best part
what so we had this article from the
Atlantic the long overdue rise of Harley
Quinn and how do I wait wait look did
you see the first sentence here it says
the character of Harley Quinn began as a
running gag so was it all just a joke no
like a running gag it's so weird she was
a character in the animated series right
she was Joker's like girl but as a joke
though but that's what that is is no no
budget character okay
and she was like smitten and would do
what he said and she was a I think she's
one of the only one of the few
comic-book characters who started in the
cartoons the annotations and move to the
comic books uh but they go on uh I don't
know if I can go through this to find
the part where they're like trying to
explain is it where is it where they
first of all this is a they're praising
it which is a lie but there's like it's
so long here we go here we go here's the
scene where she says she voted for
Bernie Sanders that's Victor Zsasz they
ruined his ass by the way
totally ruin says okay Zsasz is a serial
killer who knifes people up and he was
just a weaselly loser guy who shot
people had a gun no he did use his knife
okay that's not entirely fair yeah but
check us out
first of all Roman treats Harley as her
ex did taunting her with language that
could have been pulled from the Joker's
dialogue quote you know you can't stand
on your own he sneers it Harley you need
me
she has no relationship with the guy at
all did say that and in Angela's and she
has no relationship with him at all in
no way any point in the film
there anything about her working with
him or doing anything it makes no sense
so here's the best part so they try to
explain how the the weird dance sequence
is her finally snapping into reality oh
here we go
in one scene he slaps her repeatedly
across the face as he does she enters
into a fantasy sequence inspired by
diamonds are a girl's best friend in her
head Harley recast Roman not as the
aggressor but as a gentleman simply
asking her for a favor before she can
make it through the song though though
she shakes herself out of it realizing
she's just retreating into a delusion
behavior she once used to cope with the
Joker the film implies no it doesn't
it's literally her sitting there and all
sudden it shows her dancing
yeah and I was like I have no idea
what's happening yeah it was very like
what what is happening here it was a
dance sequence just like those scissors
okay so now here's what happens I
couldn't even finish goes there's
there's so much enough of it and turn it
off oh you missed out man you missed the
part where Chris Hemsworth was dancing
and all the cops were dancing and okay
okay okay hold on good so he's kidnapped
Harley and she's like she's gonna kill
her and she goes wait don't kill me I
could find your diamond for you and he's
like hmm that makes sense let her go and
I'm like why did he how he wanted to
kill her for no reason yeah no he wanted
to kill her for all those reasons oh
yeah because she had a China and she
voted for Bernie Sanders I'm not kidding
and then she goes if you let me go Oh
get your diamond and he goes that's a
great idea
let's go with that go and then he lets
her go and then what does she do she
leaves okay okay here's what really
bother me though there's a scene and
this is really buxom because Harley
Quinn is not a frail pathetic she's a
silent psychopathic murderer right and
there's a scene literally where she's
out in the back of the club where that
where the Black Mask owns it and black
Canary walks out and oh man
what does Black Canary see some dudes
trying to date rape Harley Quinn and
she's going I don't know I want to go
and he's that come on baby
he tries to put her in the back of a car
and I was like dude Harley Quinn is a
good character because she's insane yeah
and she would do a backflip over the guy
and twist his neck and he would die and
she would giggle and be like oopsie not
because she's like oh I'm getting
dragged away in the helpless yeah
nobody I don't think anybody who rooted
any had anything to his movie knew
anything with the characters oh manic
sense actually I know him all over the
place on this one
but I got to tell you there's a scene
yeah you guys know who Black Canary is
she's the one who can scream you know
she's in the cocido view shows oh I
don't know dude Harley Quinn is a roller
derby girl feminist Starly Quinn and she
squats like she's taken a dump and black
Canary's screams and it's the shock wave
and I'm like okay it's Black Canary and
then she rides the shock wave squatting
down on rollerskates and I'm just like
dude when they got to this part near the
end of the movie I kid you not a part of
me genuinely almost had a reaction to
grab my phone because I thought a
commercial was gonna come on I they were
it was like it was like a scene it was
like it's like I can't explain it but
you've ever seen like a made-for-tv
movie yeah where you just know the
commercials about the play yep that's
what it felt like yeah and then I
stopped I'm like dude I'm in the
theaters and like I put my hand on my
phone my own oh so the other like you
mentioned the other day that was a
straight to DVD movie yeah yeah I mean
and it was it should people shouldn't
waste their money and go see it in the
theaters you know what man I shouldn't
waste their money let me buy the DVD but
let me warn all of you who like this
movie no no no no no online just don't
know nope nope nope don't do it don't
say it don't nope don't just don't watch
it just don't watch it that's better
don't watch it no you won't you will be
angry about the 10 seconds you spent
don't watch it all right there are too
many inconsistencies with what would
happen in real life
that just that's what I was thinking
about the entire movie like that
wouldn't happen but that wouldn't happen
but I wouldn't happen and I don't think
that in other comic book movies even
when they're far-fetched even when
they're far-fetched and it's a magical
woman thing in slang whatever it's like
oh whatever but I never thought this
wouldn't happen ever the first time I
thought that was ghostbusters 2016 I was
like like what is this not this isn't
this is but it's because it's a
caricature of motivations right so
here's what I was thinking right like
what's wrong with these movies I think I
get it
in Wonder Woman was our motivation stop
the war stop
yeah about World War II yeah hey sounds
about right
yeah edge of tomorrow what's it what's
Tom Cruise motivation not the work and
the war yeah yeah
the bad alien in birds-of-prey what's
the motivation egg sandwich well yes but
but no but it's also my boyfriend broke
up with me yeah trying to find myself
right oh so it was like the semblance
Eat Pray Love with violence yeah or I'll
also save the girl but then also turn
her in but then also make her my
sidekick because there was no coherent
plot yeah yeah so here's my best part
the other night when we got out and I
tweeted like it was cats was better than
this I mean it cats was better than
birds of prey and I'm dead serious
I never seen cats but you know how
everyone was like like oh this is the
worst thing ever made Oh were they
saying that okay yeah yeah yeah but
explain in a second but sure enough I
get a blue checkmark on Twitter quote
tweeting me and he says something like I
said do not whatever you do this weekend
don't go see birds of prey it was awful
who was this movie made for here's the
quote tweet he says something like
unless you're a misogynistic insel
definitely go see this movie because
you'll greatly enjoy it and I'm just
like dude it was like it's so how about
when Harley walks into the police
station and shoots the cop in the face
with a beanbag with a beanbag grenade
launcher a one shot you have to reload
forty four millimeter redo boom shoots
the next cop in the face proceeds to
shoot like ten cops in the face and
while they're running away from her that
wouldn't have happened I don't but it
but it's okay like here's the thing man
I expect there to be some suspect
suspension of disbelief it's Harley
Quinn yeah yeah yeah but they didn't
they didn't even have her doing
impressive Harley Quinn stuff right like
in the cartoon she'll do like a like
crazy gymnastics acrobatics they did
have a little bit but was basically her
just walk in going boom boom well then
she did fight but then it was that
slow-mo thing that they did all wrong
where you can see that it was actually
exciting well so so right so like when
you do slow-motion fighting what you do
is use slow-mo the strike use the motion
of the arm before the strike and then
just before the contact is about to
happen you speed it back up yeah so it
makes it look fast yeah they didn't do
that they actually slow mode all of it
until the play hit
happened so when you're doing stunt
fighting you you'll do a fake hit and
your elbow will give or your knee will
give and they show it yeah I'm like
listen there were some aspects of it
that I was like that's pretty you know
like okay when when the eight when the
chemical plant blew up I was like that's
some cool CGI I guess but the fight
sequences were like dull and oh dude the
hair tie the hair tie the hair tie
there was a sequence where they're like
Harley Quinn somehow fight is on roller
skates now no idea how no did you even
hear them she likens it how did she
where did she find time for a shoot
change
oh dude straight up said that mid mid
baton and here it goes here goes
alright I have to say this I have to do
it Black Canary is fighting and all of a
sudden she starts trying to pull her
hair from her face and she's like uh-huh
and then Harley goes hey Italian she was
thank you and then she puts a hair tie
and keeps fighting and I was like wow
she's putting her hair up she's like
kicking guys yeah you know that whole
battle really annoyed me because black
mask brings an army they even go wow
they brought an army they open up this
cabinet there's like five guys there's
no guns though and they're like oh man
we're out of guns and they're like oh
there's this cabinet of like random a
hammer you know the classic Harley Quinn
hammer yeah no dope the mallet I finally
saw it you know and none of the army
there's like hundred guys out there you
know all guys like 200 all ready to come
in and like kill them they bring bats
and machetes and no nurse there's a
couple of I don't know I know that's
kind of okay except when they walk out
the door and answer hey the cop gets
shot so that all of a sudden they're
getting shot at it's like oh oh only the
guns guys they stayed out okay well done
Justin it would make sense for close
quarters combat
indoor they wouldn't bring the rifles in
with them sure just send a hundred guys
in but then all the guys the rifles are
standing outside and black Canary just
yells and they all blow away and then
Harley Quinn squats on a roller skate
shoots shoots through them and then like
grabs on the car and it's just like dude
who is this movie made for I swear the
way she was like smiling and giggling
and look I'm sorry Margot Robbie I think
you're a good actress and a lot of films
but this was just so you know what for
TV I'll give it to her
she she did a good job of acting in that
movie it wasn't her acting actually I
mean yeah I don't think her act was the
issue but it was it was the writing and
yeah that's true this was the writing
yeah but here's looking like the way
they were talking eating cereal though
Cassandra Cain being a little fat girl
yeah pickpocket or whatever I really
thought this movie was made for like 12
year old girls I mean that sincerely I'm
not trying to rag on it like who's made
no I mean it was literally like the
colors the hair tie stuff but there's
blood and gore you know like they show
the bad guy exploding or doings flying
everywhere okhane in the middle of a
battle yeah she does yeah and it's like
another thing make someone system all
the other day and I saw half of like Hot
Topic is like Harley Quinn you know
that's like it's all about you know
selling Harley Quinn the whole idea of
also so here's something funny you're
nailed out there yeah check this out so
this is Cassandra Fairbanks who's a big
legit Harley Quinn fan she said I hope
birds-of-prey effing flops so hard that
DC has to start making films that are
true to the source material feminist
Harley Quinn should never be a thing and
lo and behold
Jimmy Paul me ah T one of the writers
actually responds this character is true
to the comics we wrote so very true to
the source material like dead on 117
issues of Harley written by us in fact
to which Cassandra says you wrote s
comics bro guess where I'd like to I
like I'd love to get that M but she's a
she's a Harley Quinn fan though yeah
Cassandra is like a legit DC Comics okay
and fan of like the real OG Harley Quinn
okay
but I think it's funny that the dude
chimes in being like it is you know
close to the source material yeah bro
people don't like the source material
but check this out alright one more time
let's go to the so this is one of the
reviews on Rotten Tomatoes which is why
I'm calling shenanigans cuz what is this
website what Hollywood outsider it's
it's so first of all when I do reviews I
use a service called news guard
I only ever use news guard certified
this is not this is some looks like a
geocities blog from 1999 okay no offense
Hollywood outs I know trying to be mean
new episode every Wednesday but she
writes Bert birds-of-prey is a film made
by women for women about women but
operates in a capacity as enjoyable for
everyone no
everything about that sentence was
correct up on until you said it was
enjoyable for everyone I swear I look at
these these reviews and I'm calling
shenanigans on this stuff man I mean who
has the money towards that hump in like
to hire people to go and make fake you
know they have to of course because look
they made sick there's seven hundred so
much money they can definitely afford to
pay someone to just sit all day and make
an account make an email make an account
he'll make an account but you don't even
you don't even need that but I'm willing
to bet the justification is we're
getting review bombed by in sells so we
better do it right exactly so they're
saying the other the other side is doing
it like all these people are saying it's
it's a terrible film well maybe it's a
terrible face a terrible film there's no
way 88% but either way it's it's kind of
weird man it's kind of creepy because
this has got what's what's nineteen
nineteen seventeen has eighty nine
percent yet one per two mates
well that's no on the tomato tomato
meter it's five points I okay the 1917
was amazing yeah Wow
that was a that was a man that that was
a that was a good movie like a single
take it's a war film and I'll see you
mean it tell me you think this piece of
garbage okay this is scene Harley
Quinn's got a hyena someone throws a
bomb in her house and the haina runs to
the bomb and then also not that there's
an explosion and she goes oh no where's
my ena Bruce Bruce II where's where's
Brucie and he's gone and she goes ah at
the end there's the hyena just like back
with her and she's like turns out he was
just outside roaming around the Y's
district like what dude nothing made
sense I'll tell you what this movie was
if you took a bunch of college kids and
had them film like small 30-second tick
tock bits right
starring Harley Quinn and then stitch
them all together birds of prey my
favorite the very end they finally
explained with what birds of prey is
because no this is not birds of prey it
isn't it's not it's Harley Quinn going
around trying to get a sandwich sort of
I mean work or not get killed but again
everyone's basically what happens is
they find the MacGuffin the the diamond
that so inside the diamond are like
numbers scratched or something out yeah
to some like Swiss bank account or
whatever yeah and then they're like I
she ditches the birds of prey and she
goes I guess they used the money to
at a crime-fighting outfit I kid you not
Huntress and she's none of them actually
yeah she calls him like a joke yeah it's
like yeah whatever they started
something what a joke but here's the
thing
what huntresses costume looks like it
was bought it one of those Halloween
costume shops and I'm not exaggerating
you think I'm joking some trying to be
mean I'm dead serious
it was a frumpy not form-fitting
jumpsuit and she was wearing like sequin
masks over her face and I'm like dude
and I'll tell you why I'm willing to bet
the people made the movie said I don't
want to spend 10 grand on a form-fitting
movie costume for a 10-second scene yeah
it was a 10 sec so she's wearing like a
jumpsuit yeah yeah so finally Huntress
is you know look she's barely in the
film at all she so it's like when the
movie starts that the fur the cop lady
who joins the birds of prey if they're
trying to solve a murder the guy she
murdered had nothing to do with the film
I have no idea what's about well you
find out like way at the end when
Huntress actually has her lines she's
like oh I killed all the people that
matter so I'm out of here
period yeah and the people that matter
were just the guy that rented a hit on
their family and the four guys the three
guys that actually shot her family and
then knows it for some reason though it
makes no sense
she goes do you think that those guys
were acting on their own it was roman
who hired him it's like no it wasn't
that makes no sense because Romans
plotline was he was just kicked out of
the family right and he's trying to
stake out on his own to prove to his dad
yeah yeah because he was complaining
about family earlier right no you're
right so what was it though he wasn't
even part of the family 20 years ago
this happened when Roman was a teenager
and he ordered this it doesn't make
sense the guy who ordered it was an old
guy smoking a cigar right and then
huntress goes I guess you're right I
guess you're right I'll help you fight
them and that's like the first time she
talks and then and then they're like
what's your name and they're like
crossbow killer just don't call me
crossbow killer and I'm going to call me
Huntress they were trying to they didn't
have that scene where she's practicing
in the mirror yeah saying that over and
over again I'm sad because I like mary
elizabeth winstead she's in is that who
the Huntress is yeah yeah yeah she's
have been a bunch of really really good
movies you know she's in Scott Pilgrim
that was a great movie oh yeah they
actually tried to develop her character
a little bit and I was really sad that
she only got like 30 seconds because she
could have been super great and yet they
gave her they gave you the end
her entire life story you know she was
right it wasn't some relevant I know it
made no sense and in the movie yeah so
it's like sin they're two of them one of
the henchmen was a killer like like
hides that she was still alive after the
massacre right and then smuggles her
body to Italy to be trained by assassins
to come back and kill his friends so
wait wait yeah yeah because like he was
one of the assassins that write her
family right I wouldn't she has him on
the list
exempt yeah they never mention it don't
bring it up because your plot has
nothing to do with the move right it
makes no sense no okay basically Roman
wants to find the MacGuffin because he
can get access to money that's it that's
it I don't get it though he already runs
Gotham and everyone's scared of him
right he's black mask and he's got five
hundred henchmen right what he wants you
know what man no he well well it's my
diamond why are they trying to take my
diamond so basically here's the clear
okay like but I'll bet he's like so
whiny the literal plot is this this you
know this chubby little girl keeps
pickpocketing people and she steals the
diamond and then she eats it and so then
literally everyone's like we must get
the diamond the whole movie is a
MacGuffin chase yeah it's like oh the
diamond and then it's just like none of
the plot points makes sense I think the
easy way to explain it is like vine
videos or tik-tok videos strung together
and you're like I understand that these
were all filmed independently and are
not related to each other
line two connects because the same
person but there's nothing really there
so I think we kind of we kind of beat
the horse to death yes and we just watch
this movie just continue to wail on it
we used to forget this movie don't do it
yeah don't wait till it's on TV and you
can like get a gist of it because then
oh oh it's on yeah oh yeah they were
right you're gonna need your phone
you're gonna need your phone for this so
you're not gonna want to watch in the
theaters because I tell you what after
the first four or five minutes you're
gonna be like on your phone browsing or
like playing I was game just halfway
know like five or six different times
throughout the movie I was bored I was
bored and I pulled up my mobile game and
I was just just playing my mobile game
like man 1979 year 1917 was a movie
where I was like I can't wait it's over
whoa
oh really it was just like like non-stop
yeah and I start - yeah dude 1917 is
yeah and you know what let's let's talk
about the Joker that was DC that was a
man film this was a DC film wait how is
there such a drastic difference the
Joker was one of the best films I've
seen in dude maybe my lady what the
problem in this movie comes out and it's
like what I'll tell what the problem is
where's the balan DC keeps trying to
copy Marvel this was an attempt at
Deadpool well what was the Joker that
was a standalone thing that was
different that was them like taking the
guy who worked with Scorsese I think
okay was it that was was he okay I think
so anyway yeah yeah Joker look that they
did it right what they haven't always
failed Wonder Woman was good Joker was
really really good yeah Joker was
excellent it was great DC film this was
them being like can we get our own
Deadpool let's copy it it's like a copy
is never as good as the original
right and plus I'm sorry Margot Robbie
you are not Ryan Reynolds like you are
good at what you do but trying to
pretend to be like somebody else it's
not as good as to somebody but again I
don't even think that was her fault
because I mean I'm thinking about this
movie and if if they made it realistic
and not like trying to like shove men
are bad all men are terrible and women
are just the best it's like if it was
like a little women be good a little
more realistic in a sense like there was
a guy who they kept showing like the
motivation of why these guys wanted to
kill Harley Quinn and one was literally
an eggplant emoji with croc like crossed
out like yeah like what is that like he
wanted to do her I don't know like what
does it mean like you don't she doesn't
have a you know it's like it's like it
means he wants to do her okay and like
she was old and she wouldn't so yeah
gotta kill her but you know I guess I
wanted it to be better no I did I wanted
it to be you know you you keep poking at
Suicide Squad like it was like man was
that or whatever I like I actually liked
it I thought it was entertained oh I
forgot to talk about cats it wasn't that
bad Suicide Squad I liked it let's do
this I wanted we decide squad this was
not that
so let me here's the last thing I'll say
cats was weird furry people like weird
CGI that they were very horny and like
constantly rubbing on each other and it
was I was kind
like this is very strange but they were
singing okay and some of the songs I
liked like mr. Mistoffelees I thought
they really butchered memory I don't
know anything about cats so okay so cats
it what the funny thing about all this
although all the hatred cats got is now
the cats play as literally it was a book
of poems about cats and all it is is a
bunch of cats singing about what kind of
cat they are that's it okay I guess
they're in a cult or something all right
but it was funny to see other people
reviewing cats being like I don't
understand why there's no plot it's like
well then you apparently don't know what
cats is because cats has no plot right
it's literally but here's the thing cats
was boring cats I was sitting there like
it's imagine if someone said you want to
go to a theater and listen to like an
entire album like 24 songs from Zeppelin
or something you know it's gonna be like
two and a half hours long of music yeah
now you'd be like a couple of those
songs I really like you know they got
cashmere they got you know immigrant
song they got stairway a lot of them I
don't know right
so half the time you kind of like music
yeah you know exactly so you're bored
this movie was like half cringe half
bored so it was worse than cats yeah
wasn't it I mean I was gonna say it
wasn't as creepy no it's kind of creepy
too but cats was creepy because those
cat people who are really horny this was
like fringe and boring and here's the
thing sometimes you think a movie is so
bad it's funny to watch no I will admit
as you pointed out we were laughing
sometimes yeah I had the movie at the
movie not like I did laugh I did not we
were laughing yes like how awful it was
like this is ridiculous like I can't
believe this is a movie in 2020 but but
here's here's the more important thing
why you should you don't see it
you shouldn't go see it because they
were like six moments in the two hours
or whatever where you were laughing at
how bad the film was like when Holly
squats down like she's gonna take a dump
and then rides the shock wave I was like
what is this
oh man um but most time I was just like
rolling my eyes like no no they're not
gonna oh they're doing it uh I wanted to
walk out you know I didn't mm-hmm I
didn't walk out for you oh yeah yeah for
all you so that you could hear what I
had to say about how awful this movie
was
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you